[Music]
this is brewery you might look like any
other cow but there's one little thing
about him that sets him apart from his
breed brewery has never grown a pair of
horns and that wasn't a fluke of nature
parts of his DNA were rewritten by this
man
using new tools in gene-editing
scientists like him are gaining
unprecedented control over the fate of
all living things as technology replaces
old jobs it's also creating new ones I'm
Aki Ito and I'm here to show you the
jobs of the future my name is Dan
Carlson and I'm a jean editor buckle-up
the field is changing almost by the day
so new innovations new techniques gene
editing technology it's just going to
improve our lives in a number of ways
dan works for a biotech start-up called
recombinant --ax here in Saint Paul
Minnesota
so this is the embryology lab he's
tackling a problem that's plagued
farmers for generations
most dairy cattle are born with horns
which they can use to hurt each other
and their human handlers because of that
worldwide farmers remove horns from
millions of dairy calves each year it's
a painful and distressing process for
the animals dan Watts cows to be born
hornless and hopes to eliminate the
practice of dehorning altogether what we
can do on this microscope here is take
the cells that we've engineered and
create embryos out of those you might
think of Dan as some kind of mad
scientist but he's really the most
wholesome guy you can imagine he's an
excellent maker of hamburgers for anyone
he's a husband to this lovely woman and
a dad to three adorable kids Lily
do you know what your daddy works
to be clear one of the ends other
projects involves editing the genes of
pigs in case you were wondering
Dan's passion for farm animal stems from
his childhood growing up on this farm
it's run by his dad who has a very
fitting name this farm here's where my
dad started out farming I never dreamt
that there would be a scientist in high
school it was the time where the
genetically modified crops were
beginning to be planted and my dad was
one of the early adopters you could see
the difference in the crops immediately
they were taller they didn't have any
problems standing up and from that
moment on I was like this technology is
for real it can really make a difference
gene-editing songs guys science fiction
to me but I'm very proud of the work
that Dan does hungry for Darwin
dehorning cattle has always been his
least favorite part of the job when they
get their orange cut off a howler like
crazy so you know that it ain't a
comfortable thing that's happening to
him there are cows that naturally never
grow horns but they're usually used for
beef they can't produce enough milk for
dairy farmers so six years ago Dan
started working on developing hornless
dairy cattle I was interested in trying
to solve some of the problems that that
my dad encountered using a gene editing
tool that was discovered less than a
decade ago
Dan's team took a dairy cows cell cut
out the genetic segment that makes the
animal grow horns and it's walked in a
sequence found in some beef cattle that
makes him horn lists next his team
created an embryo from the edited cell
and inserted it into a surrogate mother
then they waited for nine nerve-racking
months you're expecting it to come out
without any horns or horn buds but you
just don't know
[Music]
Bree the world's first cow to be Jean
edited for hornless Ness was born in
2015 in Iowa shortly after he was
transferred here to the University of
California at Davis he's incredibly
strong I can see why I'd be dangerous to
have horns on it that's right I mean
they kind of use their head as their
defense I mean it's natural for them to
do that and obviously when you have a
1,500 pound animal moving his head
around like that doesn't take much to do
some pretty significant damage burry
became a dad to six calves in the fall
all of them inherited their fathers lack
of horns and one of them happens to be
female in a few years she's going to be
old enough to produce milk but
scientists are planning to examine Nolan
do you like cows Felix milkshakes would
you let your kids drink the milk of
Aegina did cow of course yeah yeah you
purposely buy it if it was on the market
biologists are now pouring into the
field of gene editing coming out with
new applications at dizzying speeds
if it all goes according to plan much of
it will change our lives for the better
but will there be unintended
consequences and how much tinkering with
nature is too much our answers will
shape the future a dance profession
whether this strain of animals takes off
it's really up to the government and
public acceptance I can't do a lot about
those things I just going to do my job
you